[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
قالوا لهم استتروا واختبئوا فانتم ضد
الطبيعه لكنهم لم يرضخوا ناضلوا بحثا عن
مواطنه كامله افراد مجتمع الميم عين قالوا
لهم اخجلوا واستحوا فلا حق لكم في الوجود
لكنهم لم يرضخوا ناضلوا كي يشطبوا كلمه
شواذ من القواميس والعقول اختاروا الفخر
بدل العار واثر الكبرياء بدل الذل فكان
حزيران يونيو الشهر الذي الذي جسد تمردهم
على الظلم شهر الفخر بين الماضي والحاضر
لماذا يمنع هنا ويستفز هناك في فلك
الممنوع
بدات القصه هنا في حي جرين ووتش في منهات
قبل اكثر من 50 عاما وبالتحديد في 28 من
حزيران يونيو عام
1969 في حاله
الشرطه الامريكيه هذه الحانه التي يرتادها
المثليون مداهمات ثلاث اعمال شغب وعنف
ازاء افراد مجتمع الميم عين زائد
بعد عام تم تنظيم مسيره جديده لاحياء ذكرى
مابات يعرف بانتفاضه
شارك فيها حينها حوالي 5000 شخص واطلق
عليها اسم مسيره الفخر
مرت السنوات وخرجت مسيرات الفخر من حدود
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى دول اخرى
مسيرات تزينها اعلام قوس قزح واستعراضات
فنيه على وقع الموسيقى في كل شهر يونيو من
كل عام والهدف هو التذكير بضروره استكمال
النضال من اجل مواطنه كامله ومساوات في
الحقوق لمجتمع الميم عين زائد الذي لا
يزال يعاني من خطاب الكراهيه ورهاب
المثليه
رهاب ينتشر بشكل اكبر ويصل احيانا الى حد
الاعدام في دول كاغندا وايران والسعوديه
واليمن لان غالبيه الدول العربيه تجرم في
تشريعاتها العلاقات المثليه فنحن نشعر
بالظلم
والاحتقار نتيجه منع مثل هذه المسيرات في
الدول العربيه ونتمنى ان تتقدم العقليات
في الدول العربيه
لتصل يوم الى قبول ان يخرج المثليين في
مسيرات الفخر في عواصم عربيه مشهد يبدو
بعيدا المنال بالنسبه الى افراد مجتمع
الميم عين زائد في الدول العربيه لانهم
غير مرئيين ومنبوذون في الفضاء العام اما
في الخاص فهم يواجهون رفض محيطهم
الاجتماعي بالاضافه الى ان مسيرات الفخر
غائبه عن اجندات ناشطات والناشطين في هذا
المجال لان معركتهم لا تزال في بداياتها
مع عقليات محافظه بغطاء ديني حينا
وقانونيين حين الاخر
[موسيقى]
في فلك المم
نوع هذه ستكون مع دكتور ناس محمد من
فرانسيسكو واسمه ناصر لكنه اختار ناس لانه
يسعى لان يتواصل مع كل الناس طبيب قطري
بقي في الولايات المتحده لانه قرر كسر
حاجز الصمت فكان المثلي القطري الاول الذي
يعبر عن ميوله كاشفا عن هويته ودكتور ناس
سيكون المثلي العربي الاول ايضا الذي
سيقود مسيره الفخر في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو
اهلا بك دكتور وشكرا لحضورك معنا سؤالي
الاول لك ماذا يعني بالنسبه اليك ان تكون
اول مثليه عربي وقطري يقود مسيره فخر
لمجتمع الميمعان
يعني موضوع صعب نتكلم فيه من المجتمعنا
العربي بشكل عام وكاني اني اجيك اول شخص
عربي يقول المسيره
يعني احس انها شيء يجعلني هدف للكرهن
والبث بامريكا يعني عالميا في خلال
اليومين اللي طافوا عندي وايد مسجات من
السعوديه مثلا تهديدات وهاي هو السبب نحن
لازم نطلع ونتكلم يحتاج احنا نتكلم
الاضطهادات مجتمعنا تصير سواء تكلمنا
فالشيء ما راح يتغير الا لو تكلمنا ماذا
تعني لك انت شخصيا مسيره الفخر
فهي احتجاج
ومطالبه بحمايه حقوقي كانسان هاي هي معنى
المسيره بالنسبه لك
انيولي الجنسيه او هويتي الجندريه تاخذ اي
المعايير الانسانيه اللي
تعرفني
شكرا لك دكتور سعود اليك سنتعرف على
ضيفتنا الثانيه من الرباط في المغرب ايوبه
الحمري مؤسسه جمعيه نسويات وناشطه في مجال
حقوق مجتمع الميم عين اهلا بك ايوبه
واعتذر منك لان اللغه العربيه لا تزال لا
تساعدنا في التوجه اليك كما ترغبين فانت
تعرفين عن نفسك بزاي في اللغه الانجليزيه
اي هم او هن ايوبه اولا لا مسيرات فخر في
لمجتمع الميمعان في المغرب كما في سائر
الدول العربيه هل يزعجك هذا الامر وماذا
تعني لك مسيرات الفخر
[موسيقى]
والكراهيه يعني تعتبر اليوم ان واقع شهر
الفخر تغير معمر الزمن بسبب يعني
الشق التجاري الذي الحيز التجاري الذي
اتخذته بعض المسيرات
طيب دعني اذهب الى واشنطن لنتعرف على
ضيفنا الثالث الصحفي ومذيع الاخبار في
قناه الحره جو الخولي اهلا بك جو انت اول
اعلامي عربي يخرج من الخزانه كما يقال
كسرت حواجز الخوف تقول علنا للجميع وبكل
فخر انا رجل مثلي جو كونك مقيم في
الولايات المتحده انت تشارك بفعاليات شهر
الفخر مع افراد مجتمع الميم عن زائد ومع
مناصريهم وكونك ايضا من اصول لبنانيه هل
تحز في نفسك فكره عدم تمكنك من المشاركه
في مسيرات فخر في بلدك الام يعني طبعا
هناك طبعا هناك نوع من هذا الشعور ولكن
اعرف ضمنيا السبب وراء عدم استطاعه الكثير
من المثليين وافراد مجتمعين بالمشاركه في
الشهر الفخر او بهذه المسيرات التي هدفها
الاساسي ان يقال اوقفوا الترهيب اوقفوا
الكراهيه اوقفوا خطاب التمييز ضد هؤلاء
الاشخاص كما حصلت في كل
حركات الحقوقيه المدنيه في السابق حركات
مسريه لقول لكل من يضطهد الاخر بانه يجب
ان يكون هناك
تعليه للصوت كسر حاجز الخوف ولكن هذه
المعرفه الضمنيه بعدم وجود هذه المسيرات
الفخريه كنوع من عندي
لانني اعيش في واشنطن دي سي في العاصمه في
بلد عندما وصلت اليه عرفت الفرق بين الحب
وخطاب الكراهيه التي عشت معظم حياتي
اتلقاه واكره نفسي وبالتالي كان علي هذا
هذه المسؤوليه ان اكسر حاج هذا الخوف كما
كسرته عند وصولي الى هنا وان اقول لمن
يريد ان يسمع بان ما في اي شيء غلط ليس
هناك اي خطا في الاشخاص المثليين لان هذه
كانت فكره منمطه كنت اعتقد فيها
وبالتالي عندما درست اكثر عن الموضوع في
الدين في التاريخ في العلم وجدت ان هذا
الموضوع كان موجودا في كل الحضارات
السابقه واي دين هو حق مشروع لكل الاشخاص
ان يكون معتقدهم ولكن ليس هناك حقل
الاخرين ان يمارسوا هذا الدين للتمييز ضد
الاخرين
جوسي عود اليك بعد يعني سنفتح النقاش
لاحقا حول مساله الخطا والفخر يعني
الانتقال من فكره ان ليس هناك خطا الى
الفخر الى الشعور بالفخر دعنا نتعرف فقط
على ضيفنا الرابع والاخير من لبنان لبنان
الذي ربما كان من اكثر الدول العربيه
الباحثه للتفاؤل في احتمال ان يتمكن افراد
مجتمع المعي من الخروج يوما ما الى الفضاء
العام دون ان يتعرضوا للمضايقه لكن
السنوات الاخيره قلبت الموازين فمنعت كل
النشاطات المتعلقه بهم وباتوا يشعرون
بتهديد اكبر على وجودهم كافراد اذن من
لبنان ارحب بضيفنا الرابع من تحديد من
بيروت المتخصص في دراسات للجندر ومدير
جمعيه موزاييك شربل ميدع اهلا بك شربل هل
فسرت لنا لماذا اليوم هذه المسيرات مسيرات
الفخر في شهر الفخر تزعج حد القمع
والاعتداءات الجسديه سواء لدى شرائح
محافظه في الدول الغربيه التي احرز
التقدما كبيرا في مجال حقوق
[موسيقى]
واخذوا الممثلين والمثليات بوقتها حقوقهم
بامريكا هو تسكير عن انه في اشخاص ضحوا
بكثير امور بحياتهم لا يقدروا يحصلوا على
حقوقهم كمواطنين
يعني ابتدا
اول افتتاح
مضبوط حاليا ليش بيخافوا كميه كميه
العائلات
يلي بتشارك بالبرايت كميه الاشخاص ان
كانوا مبدئيا بشاركوا كميه العالم الهائله
اللي بتنزل تدعم
الاختلاف والمحافظه على حقوق الاقليات
بالمجتمعات بتخوف اليمين المتطرف اكيد
لانه بيتفقده سلطه هن كانوا عاده
بيستعملوها
يعني تيطلعوا على السلطه الاجتماعيه
والسلطه السياسيه لفقدت بدول الغرب حاليا
وبعدنا نحن عم نعاني منها بدولنا
شرقيه من منظوره جندر
بمجتمعاتنا الشرقيه هو مساس كثير كبير للذ
كوريه
للعادات والتقاليد
المتحيز للجنس الذكوري قال لي كل نار
عليها ولا كلنا نستطيع منها اذا بدك من
الصبح لبعد ما فهيدي اكيد امور ما يلا
حيحطوا هيحطه يعني تستفز الذكوريه بالنسبه
اليك ذكوريه المجتمعات طيب دعني اذهب الى
اعود الى
يعني اليوم مصطلح الفخر مصطلح الكبرياء هي
مصطلحات مكروهه وهناك ايضا يعني نفور منها
خاصه لدى المتدينين يعني اليوم مثلا هناك
في القران الكريم
ايه تقول ان الله لا يحب كل مختال فخور
وفي المسيحيه الفخر او التفاخر هو بمثابه
خطيئه لماذا يوم هذا المفهوم لماذا الفخر
وليس مثلا نحن هنا او يعني لماذا وهل
تعتبر ان هذا ربما سبب في استفزاز الناس
الذين يعتبرون ان هذه المسيرات مستفزه
الهدف من استعمال المصطلح مقبل للاختزاز
احنا قاعدين نفكر في الاشخاص اللي قاعدين
يمرون في التجربه ويعانون لان فتره
التجربه كشخص مثلي نفسي
فما اجتمع يعني حسسني بالعار وبعدم
الانطماء وحسسني انه اعطاني خيارين يا اما
اتقبل نفسي واخسر كل اخسر كل الاشياء
الثانيه لما نستعمل مصطلح الفخر احنا
قاعدين نكلم الناس اللي قاعدين يعانون
نبههم يحسون بامل علشان يقدرون يعيشون كل
يوم في حياتهم وما يفقدون الامل ويختارون
الانتحار او اي شيطاني
اليوم بالنسبه اليك هل حملات الكراهيه او
هل يعني كل من يعتبر او ما يعتبر ان شهر
الفخر او مسيرات الفخر التي ينظمها افراد
مجتمع الميم عين
هي مستفزه
برايك هل ما يقف وراء هذا هذا الخطاب هو
اساسا التدين ام العقليات ام يعني اين
تكمن المشكله بالتحديد ام كما قال شرب منذ
قليل التركيبه الذكوريه ربما للمجتمعات
هو ليس الدين الجميع عنده حق يكون عنده
معتقدات دينيه
ولكن التطرف بالفكر هو الذي يؤدي الى
الكراهيه دعا الخلق للخالق كل شخص له حق
يكون عنده معتقدات نحن ما عم نفرض
معتقداتنا وقت عم نعمل مسيره الفخر اما
بالنسبه للاسم فخر برايد هو اعتزاز يعني
هو اعتزاز
بالشخصيه الحقيقيه لكل واحد منا لانه احنا
قبل هذا البرايد كان مطلوبه من المجتمع
يكون في تنميط واخفاء لهذه الهويه نحن
قلنا لا لم نخفي هذه الهويه بقى هناك قمع
لهؤلاء الاشخاص وبالتالي اي تقدم
فيقول لك مثلا سانقل يعني وانا سالعب هذا
الدور اليوم مثلا ما قد يستفز من اليوم
تعلم ان مسيرات الفخر هي مسيرات ربما يعني
اصبحت موجوده كثيرا على وسائل الاعلام
ووسائل التواصل يتم التعامل معها طبعا
بمختلف الطرق ولكن هناك مشاهد ربما يعني
تحدث بمثابه صدمه لدى الناس منها مثلا
عندما نرى رجال متنكرين بازياء نساء او
الدراكوينز يعني او مثلا مشاهد على
العربات لرجال بملابس داخليه عراه يعني
برايك اليوم
هل الاستفزاز متعمد من هذه الناحيه هل
اليوم الذهاب نحو العري او استخدام العري
هو تفضل تفضل
هذا سؤال المليون دولار ولكن لماذا نحن
نركز على هذا الموضوع
ونسينا في الماضي يعني كل الاستفزازات نحن
تعرضنا لان كان مشاهد في التلفزيون
ولافلام اباحيه او لحتى رسوم المتحركه كان
نوع معين واضح هو للمجتمع المغاير لم لم
نصبح مغيرين كاشخاص مثليين وبالتالي ايضا
المشاهد الاباحيه كانت موجوده منذ زمن
طويل ان كان بالحضارات الاغريقيه او
الرومانيه او حتى الى عصرنا اليوم هناك
مشاهد اباحيه موجوده ومتفشيه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وبالتالي نحن عندما
نختار انه فقط نصوب على المشاهد الاباحيه
للمثليين يعتبرها خطا اما المشاهد
الاباحيه الموجوده المتفشيه اليوم في
اماكن ومطاعم في الولايات المتحده ياخذ
الاهل اولادهم معظم النساء اللي هن تعملن
كناديلات شبه عاريات ما عندهم مشكله في
الموضوع وبالتالي التركيزنا اليوم على هذه
النقطه خط ا حتى يعني انتقاء بعض النصوص
الدينيه لتوجيها ضد مجتمع المثليين ولكن
انا بدي اسال لماذا هذا الانتقاء من
النصوص المقدسه هناك عبوديه
انه شهر الفخر هو تحدي لله
للذات الالهيه يعني لماذا هو التحدي عندما
يعني هناك اديان مختلفه
ليس لديها مشكله مع المثليه هناك سكان
اصليين وديانات عندهم ما يعرف او ذوي
الروحين الجنسين يعني هناك ديانات اخرى
تسمح بهذا الموضوع لا اعرف لماذا هذه
النقطه بالتحديد يعني انت مسموح عندك تكون
حق بدينك ولكن لا بتفرد دينك على حياتي
ممكن اشخاص يكونوا غير دينيين اولاديين
ولكن في هذه النصوص انا اللي بدي اقول
يعني هو انتقاء لهذه النصوص لا التهميش ضد
المجتمع الميم عين ولكن هناك عثور على
اشارات للعبوديه بالنصوص المقدسه تتضمن
مبادئ ومعامله العبيد هل نحن بمجتمعنا
اليوم بال2023 نسمح بالعبوديه وممكن ان
نرجع الى هذه النصوص المقدسه لنقول انه
العبوديه مسموحه لا هناك تطور بمجتمعاتنا
هذه النصوص كتبت ب معينه ولكن حط اذا بدنا
نرجع مضبوط لندرس هذه النصوص وترجمتها
بالمسيحيه المسيح لما يتحدث عن المثليه
لبل قال لا تدينك لا تداني وتبدل
المسيحيين او المسلمين او ان كنت تقرف انا
بعرف
وبيروحوا على الجامع وما عندهم مشكله وما
عندهم مشكله صح صح طيب الجوده يعني اسال
ايوبه عن مساله العري لانه ربما يعني
هي مساله قد تكون فلسفيه ايضا هناك حركات
تحرريه كثيره في العالم منها نسويات
استعملنا العوريكا كسلاح ربما الايصال
الرساله ما او للتعبير عن اضطهاد ما هل
انت
توافقين على هذا النوع من
الاستخدامات للتعريف في مكان ما ام انك
تعتبرين كما قالت جو انه يعني هذه فقط
يعني هذا جزء من المشهد وليس المشهد بعينه
كنعتقد كاين مغالطات بزاف على النسويه
وعلى التحرريه المجتمع العين زائد بالضبط
كما قال الجو بانه يعني الصور النمطيه
التي كتخلينا نعرفو بان منين غادي نسمحوا
بالاشخاص المجتمعين زائد في المجتمع يعني
غادي يخرجو يعني عاريات وعاريين في الشارع
الامر اللي هو مختلف تماما على المتطلبات
ديالنا حنا كمناضلات ومنظرين متطلبات
ديالنا احنا
الحقوق الاساسيه الحق في الامن والامان
الحق في الصحه الحق في الدراسه الحق في
المكان العمومي
الناس
بمبادئ مختلفه اماكنش مبدا غالط وما كاينش
مبدا صحيح فكنعتقد ايضا يعني الوضعيه
المحليه كتخلينا نختار يعني استراتيجيات
اللي غادي تخلي الناس يعني يكون يتقبلوا
اكثر الوضعيه وك
يعني الصدمه هي جزء من النضال الناس اللي
كيستعملوا يعني الاسلوب الصدمه فهذاك اللي
كيبقى اسلوب ما كنقولش
كيبقى اسلوب بين مجموعه ديال الاساليب
اريد ان اسالك عن يعني مساله ربما تثير
الانقسام ايضا في اوساط مجتمع افراد مجتمع
الميم عين زائد يعني مساله كيف
تطورت مسيرات الفخر او كيف تطورت تطور شهر
الفخر مع مر الزمن يعني بدانا من نضال يتم
فيه قتل المثليين في الولايات المتحده
واعتقال المثليين ويعني ارتكاب فضاعات
بحقهم وصلنا اليوم في المجتمعات الغربيه
الى مسيرات فخر فيها استعراضات فنيه فيها
رقص فيها موسيقى
برايك هل يعني هل هل يسخف هذا الامر ربما
قضيه قضيه او المطالب الحقوقيه او القضيه
الحقيقيه لافراد المجتمع الميمعان ام لا
بالنسبه لالي بالنسبه للاشخاص اللي عم
بيحتفلوا ببلدانهم بهذا الشهر بهذه
الطريقه هو بالعكس هو حقهن يفتخروا وحقهم
بالتسكير بالنضال اللي قطعوا فيه وحقهم
يقولوا للجيل الجديد ما تخافوا نحن بعد
عنا وجود بالشارع نحن اختار ونحن عم نحتفل
تنحافظ على حقنا تميزه حدا وخاصه عم
بحاولوا حاليا يرجع ياخد هيدي الحق منا
اما بالنسبه لتداعيات هيدي وخاصه مع
السوشيال ميديا والانفتاح العالمي على كل
شيء بصير باي بلد تكون على اطلاعب وين ما
كنت عم باثر سلبا للاسف على نحنا
يعني احنا المسيره يلي بعدين نحطنا لاننا
عم بتاثر لانه العالم بكره حنصير بدنا
زواج مصريين احنا بكره بننزل بالزلط على
الشوارع وهو مش بالنسبه
العربيه مش هيدا هو هدفنا هدفنا الاول
مثلا الغاء القوانين يلي بتجرب المثليين
اعتق حقوق صحيه للعبرين والعابرات يعني
عنا عنا
بسبب ميول الجنسي او توجهي اكيد او
الاساسيه نحن بعدنا هون بس اكيد انا كمان
فخور بالاشخاص اللي بيختخروا بتاريخهم
وبيكونوا عم يحتفلوا بهذا الشهر لتاريخ
يعني مهما كانت مع الاسلوب هو حق لاي
انسان يعني وبالتالي ربما الحكم عليه هو
المشكله اريد ان اسال دكتور ناس يعني
دكتور ناس اليوم في 2023 ما هو الشعار
الاقرب الى قلبك انت كرجل تنتمي الى مجتمع
الميم عين زائد ما هو الشعار الذي تريد ان
ترفعه في شهر الفخر
اسم مسيرتي اللي امشي فيها هالسنه اسمها
الحب ليس جريمه
والناس اللي راح يمشون معاي ما راح افراد
مجتمعين
معاي بنكون
وعابرين جنسيا يعني يعني
القصد ان تقول انه هذه هذا الحدث لا ينحصر
فقط بافراد مجتمع الميمعان
مدافعه حقوق الانسان راح تتطلب المجتمع
ككل يجيه وراه
حتى مثلا مختلفين عنا لا نتقبلنا
الناس
تفضل دكتور الناس لانه شوي ما سمعنا
للانسان
يتحزثها لازم تجارما
باي صفه
يعني
تجريم مجتمع بين عين لازم لماذا برايك
لماذا برايك دكتور ناس اليوم وانت لديك
دعوه الى الحب او دعوه الى الى يعني الى
تغليب الحب على الكراهيه لماذا رغم هذه
الدعوه لازلت تتلاقى هذا الكم الهائل من
التهديدات ومن خطاب الكراهيه ومن الحقد
سؤال صح لنا احس الطب بصراحه رايي الشخصي
وهو عدم
المرئيه ان تكون مرئيه نعم
لان الناس متفاهمين الموضوع اذا في شيء ما
تشوفه قدامك طول الوقت بتخاف منها فعشان
كده هاي الحفله هالشهر مهمه جدا لان نبي
نعرف الناس عن مجتمعنا انبي نكسر كل
الحواجز والافكار النبطيه الموجود
المتوجهه ضد المجتمع لمين عين طيب بالحديث
عن الافكار النمطيه تجوا اريد ان اسالك
يعني ربما بعض ما يحصل في في في مسيرات
الفخر قد يكرس الى حد ما الصور النمطيه هل
يعني هناك ربما تفكير بكيفيه محاربه هذا
الامر او بكيفيه العمل على ان لا يحصل
وبالتالي هناك دائما حركه طويله من النضال
للحقوق والمساوات بين كل البشر واحنا
مدركين لهذا الموضوع ومدركين والتاريخ
واضح اليوم عندما يتم الحديث عن هذه
الامور هو تشويش هو المفروض اليوم كثير من
المعلومات المضلله وسوء الفهم والخلط بين
الحب والجنس يعني هلا قبل قليل مثلا في
صور على السوشيال ميديا تنتشر بانه حقها
الكوفيد هي تؤدي الى تحول جنسي يعني هل
معقول نحن بال
1923 يكون عنا هيك نوع من غباء علمي بقرن
في ذكاء اصطناعي البشر عقل الى الخلف يعني
دكتور ناس ممكن يجاوب على هذا السؤال هناك
تخويف غير مبرر دائم نحن شغلتنا ننشر
الوعيك اشخاص مثل الموجودين اليوم ناشطين
لا شيء طب لماذا هناك لا شيء لانه بعرف
هناك تخويف لانه الحاقد دائما يخوف خلال
حركه الحقوق المدنيه من اجل المساواه
العرقيه في الولايات المتحده هناك كان
تخويف من السود من العرق الاسود من اشخاص
بشرتهم داكنه هل هذا خوف مبرر انت
باعتبارك اليوم نحن نعيش في 2023 حتى
العبوديه كان اهلها ما بين النصوص القديمه
صح وبالتالي عندما يدرك المرء باعتزاز
هويته انه انا اريد ان اكون موجود بحب انا
ماني ضدك انا اطالب بحقوقي ليس انتقاصا من
حقوقك من قطعه بيتزا يعني الحقوق المدنيه
بمعامله الاشخاص مدنيا غير دينيا بحقوق
متساويه وحقه بالوجود والتنفس بحريه لا
ينتقص من حق الاخرين ووجود والتنفس بحريه
طيب
يعني
في اطار اليوم هذا خطاب الكراهيه الذي
للاسف الشديد يعني مستعر جدا نراه مستعرا
على مواقع التواصل خاصه في الحسابات
الناطقه باللغه العربيه برايك اليوم ما هي
يعني هل كيف يساهم شهر الفخر او كيف تساهم
مسيرات الفخر اليوم بكسر هذه الصور
النمطيه ما هي الاساليب التي يجب يعني
العمل عليها من اجل تفسير مساله الحقوق
المدنيه التي تحدث عنها جو
كان ممكن نمزج الاساليب اللي زعما الاشخاص
في المنطقه يعني
سنوات اللي مازال لحد الان كيشتغلوا
العيال ديال رفع التوعيه يعني كنضمن اللغه
العربيه كيما قلتي في الاول هي لغه يعني
ثنائيه يعني فيها هو او انت بزاف ديال
المغالطات ايضا في اللغه العربيه ومصطلحات
اللي ما معروفينش فكن احنا كمناضرين
ومناظرات مثلا دينا اشتغال على اللغه
العربيه كيفاش نردوها يعني اكثر شموليه
واكثر تقبل للاخر
يستفز يعني الكثير الكثير من الناس يعني
يراسلوننا او نتحدث اليهم يعتبرون انه
يعني اوكي نفهم المطالبه بالحقوق المدنيه
ولكن تريدون حتى ان تغيروا اللغه كيف ترد
على هذا النوع من الافكار
تغيير اللغه لانها نرجعو اللغه ملائمه
العصر الحالي كانهم بان
الانسان كيتطور بطبيعته
تطور ايضا يعني اللغه خاصها تكون اكثر
شموليه اللي تضمن اشخاص
اللغه ما تعتبرهم سنوات الماضيه ولا في
الماضي يعني بالاساس ماشي واكثرت
يعني في العصر ديالنا الحالي ساسال شارب
من بيروت شربل اليوم يعني برايك هل يمكن
لافراد مجتمع الميم عن في لبنان
ما المخاطر التي قد تحصل في حال قرر قرروا
النزول الى الشارع
والاحتفال او احياء ذكرى شهر الفخر
ما الذي سيحصل
للاسف وبكل للاسف وبكل صراحه عم بحكي
حاليا يعني وخاصه بهذا الشهر نحن بهيدا
الشهر
حاليا عم بتم تهديد جمعيه حلم بالتسكير من
قبل جمعيات من قبل الجمعيات متطرفه وبدعم
من وزاره الداخليه اللبنانيه على تخريج
جمعيه انه تسكر عم بتم تهديد جمعيات
نسائيه بمهرجانات بهذا الشهر
وتهديدهم في حال وجود اي ساينز للمجتمع
الميم معين بلس معقوله يهجموا للاسف ما في
دوله
فنحن عم بنكون صلاحها كتير حذرين على
انواع النشاطات لانه في خوف
من سنتين عفوا
ماذا قلت
عم قول انه من سنتين حتى انزعجوا من ورود
ملونه وزربوا انه جربوا كسروها وانزعجوا
منها ان كان اشخاص متطرفين مسيحيين او
اسلام من الاثنين ومش عم بحكي عن ديانه
وحده للاسف بدولتنا بعد الطوائف بمحل معين
لانه نحن دوله طائفه
ممثله بالمجلس النيابه فنحن مش قادرين
نفصل بين الحكم البدني على الحكم الطائفه
مش بس بالاحوال الشخصيه لا لبال اصلا بكل
المواضيع الاجتماعيه المجتمعيه بعد في
تدخل دينه بالموضوع وهيدا ونحن بنرجع
بناكد نحن ما اجزاكلي ما عم نقرب على
ديانه حدا ولا عم نقول لا انتم ما عم
بحقلكم
تمارسوا دينتكم بس كمان ما تيجوا تلعبوا
دور الله علينا وما تعكسوا
ثقافاتكم بقوانين تؤذي المجتمع وبتكبت
لاختلافه لاكتر ولا اقل بس للاسف الوضع
خطير حاليا الوضع خطير في لبنان يعني على
اليوم على افراد معلمين
يصن اليوم بالحديث عن يعني
لما بقول خطير بس بدي اركز على شغله خطير
للناشطين والنشطات بس مش خطير مثلا للسهر
والحفلات رواق عادل حياه مكمله بس لما
تتنظمي وتطلبي بحقوق هون هلا كتير زي هذه
الخطوره حاليا بلبنان شكرا شكرا دكتور لك
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن لبنان يعني ربما لان
لبنان يمر بازمه مؤخرا قد يكون يعطي مثالا
على ان الدوله او طبيعه الدوله او شكل
النظام او المؤسسات في الدوله مهمه جدا
ايضا من اجل المطالبه بحقوق افراد المجتمع
الميم عن هل تعتبر اليوم ان اي تغيير
حقوقي في الدول العربيه يجب ان يتضمن
تغييرا او ان يسبقه تغييرا سياسيا
يعني
دولي وتغيير في المجتمع على مستوى
وحنحتاج الشركات غير مناظمهم نحتاج
المنظمات الصحيه تغير قوانينها راح نحتاج
المدارس راح نحتاج منظمات الاعلام تتغير
وراح نحتاج نغير اشياء كثيره علشان نساند
الاقليه الجنسيه في الدول العربيه وهو مو
بس راح يكون شيء واحد اذا غيرناك السويتش
خلاص راح يتغير الموضوع كله لا احنا كلنا
لازم نقعد ونشتغل مع بعض ونتكلم على بعض
عشان نقدر نحمي الاقليات في دولتنا مهما
كانت الاقليات
اليوم احنا قاعدين نتكلم على الاقليات
الجنسيه والجندريعيه لكن لازم يكون هلكو
تفكيرنا عن حمايه اي اقليه انسانيه اي
اقليه على اي حال هو هو التوجه نحو
المساواه يعني بغض النظر عن الاصل او
الميل الجنسي او اللون او الى هنالك يعني
طيب تجو الى اي مدى تعتبر انت ان قضيه
اليوم مجتمع الميم معين هي قضيه تتشابك مع
امور اخرى مع ملفات اخرى تحدث دكتور ناس
عن المدارس عن التعليم انا تحدثت عن
السياسه الى اي مدى برايك هذه الامور يجب
ان تكون بشكل موازي او ان يعمل عليها بشكل
موازي ام ان هناك اولويات اليوم يعني يجب
العمل السياسيا اولا قبل الوصول الى امور
اخرى
الاولويات بكل العالم هي ان يكون هناك
مساوات بين الحقوق البشر والانسان لانه ما
يعرف باللغه الانجليزيه
يعني هناك تزاوج بين كل القضايا اليوم
بقول لك اه في مثلا في لبنان وضع الفقر
ولكن هناك مثل فقير هناك مثلا اشخاص نساء
يتعرضن للعنف ايضا هناك مثليات نساء تتعرض
التداخل في القضايا ما هي القضيه الاقرب
الى قلبك يعني حقوقيا من بعد من بعد مجتمع
المي معانجه
يعني الدفاع عن كل القضايا كل القضايا
يعني ما في قضيه وحده انا ادافع عن كل
قضايا التي تتعلق بحقوق الانسان بغض النظر
عن عرقن ودين وميولهم الجنسيه ولكن اريد
ان اشير الى نوع من نفاق عندما يتحدث شربل
عن الموضوع الدينا هناك
المتطرفين المتدينين لانه لا مشكله معنا
نحن مع الاشخاص المتدينين انا اتيت من
عائله متدينه ولكن لا فرق بين الدين الدين
ينشر الحب هناك نفاق باختيار بعض النصوص
الدينيه في لبنان هناك فرقه متطرفه شبيهه
لداعش انا بالنسبه الي هي جنود الرب شبيهه
لداعش لا فرق بين التطرف الديني الاسلام
او التطرف الدين المسيح التطرف وتطرف
هؤلاء الاشخاص يختارون بعض النقاط او بعض
النصوص مثلا بصفر اللاوين اللي بيتحدثوا
فيها عن
المثليه ولكن هي هذا الموضوع لا يتحدث عن
مثلي ولكن ايضا في سفر اللاويين ممنوع على
الرجال ان يقصوا اللحيه ممنوع على الرجال
ان يلبسوا اقمشه من من نوع مخت ممنوع على
الانسان ان ايضا يتناول الصدفيات ولكن
ايضا في هذه النصوص الدينيه بنتحدث عن
عبوديه اذا هم يختارون هم ما عندهم مشكله
بيلبسوا غير انواع قماش بقصوا اللحيه ما
عندهم مشكله بكل هذا الموضوع بطريقه ما
عندهم مشكله فيها ولكن بدينه غير هناك
انتقائيه وبدينه
خلينا نختاره ونقول كمان الاشي اللي انتم
عم تعملوها ولكن انتقائيه غير مبرره وغير
صحيحه وايضا بمحل ما في خوف دائما على
الاطفال ما يصلون هيدي نقطه كتير مهمه
الاطفال اليوم في سفر.
اذا بدنا نتحدث عن اعتداءات جنسيه عم
بتصير من قبل مجتمع الميم ولكن الاعتداءات
الاكبر 90% الارقام والاحصاءات بتشير انه
90% تحصل من اقارب داخل العائله وايضا لن
ننسى الاعتداءات الجنسيه التي يقوم بها
رجال الدين على الاطفال وبالتالي اذا كان
الخوف على الاطفال لازم نخاف من فعلا
الارقام المخيفه التي تح صل وليس من
المثليين وليس من المثليين تمام ايوبه
اريد ان اسالك هل تعتبرين اننا قريبا ربما
في السنوات المقبله قد نشهد مسيرات فخر في
عواصم عربيه ام ان هذا الامر بعيد المنال
جدا جدا
الصراحه انا شخصيا كنعتبرش مسيره الفخريه
اولويه ديال زعما حاليا كشخص في المغرب
كاين اشياء اخرى اللي كنعتبرها اكثر اهميه
مثلا الحق في الاشخاص يكملوا الدراسه
ديالهم يعني ما يكونش عنف ما يكونش
في الشغل في مكان العمل او ما يكونش ايضا
عنف مجتمعي ان يكون واحد الحمايه واحد
الاطار قانوني اللي كيحمي الاشخاص
اللي كنت
كنتكلمو عليها يعني بعد حين كان ان الحقوق
الانسان ما فيهاش اولويات ولا تتجزا يعني
في المغرب هو حقوق اساسيه يعني حقنا بس
عند الوجود وان ما يكونش اطار قانوني اللي
كيجرب التواجد ديالك في واحد المجتمع اللي
هو من حقك انك تعيش فيه الحق في الصحه
الحق في يعني
مكان العمومي يعني
تطلبينه اليوم هذه المطالب الحقيقيه
لمجتمع الميم عين زائد في المغرب متفائله
في المستقبل سيحدث تغيير ام لا
على حقوق ديالهم
ولا اكثر الشيء اللي هو الظهور اصلا
[موسيقى]
من مختلف الدول العربيه والان طلعنا
هالسنه ومشينا المشي مو بس لنا هاي المشيه
اللي بكل شخص عربي من مجتمع الميم عين
عايش في اي واقع حاليا واتمنى انه يقدروني
تشوفون ان احنا مش عايشين بنفسهم وان حتى
لو المسيره تعطي امل للشخص واحد بدكم
تعطيهم احساس
يسموني يدافعون
ناس شرب الكلمه اخيره لك اليوم ما هي
الرساله ربما او الكلمه التي تود ان
تقولها في الختام
على طول نذكر فيه انه ما رح نفقد الامل
واكيد حيجي اليوم
ونحذف فيه القوانين يلي بتجربنا
بحب وصايه صغيره للاشخاص اللي هن عايشين
برات بلداننا العربيه انه ينتبهوا رديت
الفعل السلبيه اللي معقول تصير على
الاشخاص اللي عايشين بقلب بلداننا بس
بحاجه لنشاط عم بيقوموا فيه يتذكروا انه
في اشخاص بعدهم بالبلدان ويجربوا قد ما
فيهم يعملوا امور كمان ما يسبب باي اذى
دايره
وسهل فخر مبارك للجميع
لو سمحت اختم معك الكلمه الاخيره لك يعني
اليوم انت
تمكنت ربما من ان تصنع فارقا في الصوره او
في المشهد الاعلامي الناطق باللغه العربيه
عندما قررت ان تقول للجميع انني انا مثلي
وافتخر ما الذي تريد ان تقوله اليوم لمن
يشاهدك
الطريق نحو القبول الكامل وعدم تجريم اي
انسان طويل
2008 كان هناك فقط 45 او 54 دوله الغي
التجريم المثليه اليوم بال2023 هناك 133
دوله الغت تجريم المثليه كل جزء من التقدم
لو كان صغير مهم كثير ونحن رح نضل مستمرين
ولكن اريد ان اطرح سؤال على كل الهوموفوز
والاشخاص الحاقدين شو هو بدل ما تنشروا
الكراهيه ضد شخص ما لانه بحب على طريقته
شو هو الشيء اللي عملتوه بحياتكم تنشروا
وتخلوا العالم اليوم افضل من العالم اللي
جيتوا فيه يوم امس هذا بس سؤال صغير شكرا
على استضافتكم والحديث دائما نحو المساواه
وقبول الاخر شكرا لك يا جو كل التوفيق لك
ولكل الضيوف ومسيرات الفخر هي اكثر من
مجرد احتفال النقاش في الفلك الممنوع لا
نهايه له نترك لك ولك حريه التفكير وحريه
الاختيار تابعونا في حلقات جديده دائما
على شاشه
الدوليه تحياتي